The answer is yes. She'd have to throw the object faster.
When I approach questions like this in physics,
I think of what I call limiting cases.
For example, I ask myself what if gravity were 0?
Well, if there was no gravity, the object wouldn't be attracted to the earth at all.
If you threw it in some direction it would just go floating forever.
As I increase that gravity, I can see that, okay, maybe the object will start to get pulled towards earth.
If I make gravity huge, almost infinite, the object will always be attracted to the center of the earth.
It seems like the trend is that if gravity is stronger, you have to throw it a little harder.
If it's weaker, you don't have to throw it as hard to maintain the circular orbit.
Now, remember when Dr. Fara said that there were 2 reasons why the Principia Mathematica
was truly revolutionary? We can now go to the first one.
[Dr. Fara] It establishes one single law of gravitation
that extends right through the whole universe.
Before that--well, a couple of hundred years before that--
everybody followed the Aristotelian idea that there was one set of laws on earth
and a completely different set of laws up in the heavens,
so that in the heaves everything is perfection and unchanging and eternal,
and on earth everything is changing and corrupt.
Galileo first but the Newton brought all those changing ideas together
and said, no, there's one force that extends right through the universe.